hola bienvenidos en este vídeo quiero
responder una pregunta sencilla
imagínense que van en un avión que va
volando y lo que quieren saber es cuál
es la distancia al punto más lejano que
pueden ver sobre la superficie de la
tierra entonces vamos a suponer las
siguientes cosas vamos a suponer que la
altura a la que está volando el avión la
altura es de 10 kilómetros esta altura
es bastante realista los aviones
generalmente vuelan muy cerca de esa
altura y otra cosa que voy a necesitar
para resolver este problema es el radio
de la tierra el radio de la tierra que
de hecho la tierra no es una esfera
perfecta pero para este problema voy a
suponer que si lo es entonces el radio
de la tierra
es de seis mil 371 kilómetros y como les
digo esto no es un número constante
varía sobre la superficie pero para
nuestros efectos este número será
suficientemente bueno y bien los invito
a ponerle pausa al vídeo y tratar de
pensar en este problema por ustedes
mismos si van en un avión que está a 10
km sobre la tierra está volando a 10
kilómetros de altura entonces cuál es la
distancia al punto más lejano sobre la
superficie de la tierra que pueden ver
porque quizás estén diciendo bueno puedo
ver las estrellas o algo así pero no
queremos quedarnos sobre la tierra bueno
entonces asumiré que pasaron el vídeo y
entonces lo que voy a hacer para empezar
es dibujar a la tierra ahora como les
digo la tierra no es un círculo perfecto
pero lo voy a dibujar como tal para
efectos ilustrativos y bueno entonces
este puntito aquí este dibujo para nada
esta escala no se vayan a ir con la
cinta no esta escala este puntito aquí
representa el avión y el avión está a 10
kilómetros y es kilómetros de
la superficie de la tierra ahora si
quisiera continuar hasta el centro de la
tierra entonces el centro está de la
superficie a una distancia de 606 mil
371 kilómetros es bastante lejana la
superficie al centro de la tierra bueno
y ahora qué pasa si me fijo por la
ventanilla pues esencialmente mis rayos
de visión son líneas rectas entonces el
punto más lejano y ahorita discuto esto
con un poco más de cuidado es
precisamente la línea que es tangente a
la circunferencia es por el punto que
representa mi avión y porque es este
pues imagínense que quisiera ver este
punto acá como están más lejos que la
tangente o no es la tangente en sí
entonces tiene que cortar otro punto de
la superficie más cercano a el avión en
el que estoy volando digamos a este
punto
ven como corta la superficie en este
otro punto por lo tanto no puedo
realmente ver este punto desde el avión
entonces bueno lo que quiero hacer es
averiguar esta distancia de aquí esto
que voy a nombrar x quiero averiguar
cuánto vale x y este punto yo sé que
como estoy asumiendo que la tierra es
una esfera perfecta entonces esta
distancia aquí también son seis mil 371
kilómetros esto es un radio y además yo
sé que como esto es una tangente la
longitud x es una tangente o más bien la
línea la línea color crema es una
tangente entonces este ángulo de aquí es
un ángulo recto bien y ahora quizás esto
ya les está haciendo que suenen cosas
dentro de su cabeza porque ahora puedo
aplicar el teorema de pitágoras para
decir
x al cuadrado x al cuadrado que sería
este cateto de aquí la longitud de este
cateto al cuadrado más 6 mil 371
6.371 al cuadrado que sería la longitud
de este cateto me tiene que dar la
longitud de esta hipotenusa al cuadrado
pero cuánto es la longitud del tipo t
nusa pues esto va a ser igual a
6.371 que sería la distancia del centro
a la superficie más los 10 kilómetros
que tiene altura mi avión más 10 y ahora
si todo esto al cuadrado
escrito de otro modo esto es lo mismo
que x al cuadrado más 6 mil 371 6.371 al
cuadrado debe ser igual a 6 mil 371 + 10
es 6.381 al cuadrado
o escrito incluso de otro modo esto
sería lo mismo que x al cuadrado es
igual a
6.381 al cuadrado
menos
- 6.371 al cuadrado o incluso de otro
modo puede escribir esto como x es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de
6.381 al cuadrado
- 6.371 al cuadrado y como es una
distancia como x es una distancia me
puedo quedar con la raíz cuadrada
positiva y ahora sí déjenme saco mi
calculadora
bien entonces quiero la raíz cuadrada de
6.381 al cuadrado al cuadrado menos seis
mil 371 al cuadrado
y cuánto es eso esos son 350 y 7.09
entonces aproximadamente 357 kilómetros
bien entonces dije que x era
aproximadamente 357 kilómetros es decir
si yo me asomo de la ventana del avión
entonces esta distancia es de 357
kilómetros y esta instancia también es
de 357 kilómetros en cualquier dirección
podría haber a 357 kilómetros asumiendo
que el día sea suficientemente claro
pero bueno eso qué significa cómo
podemos dimensionar eso pues déjenme
trato de hacer un mapa por acá abajo que
de nuevo no está dibujado escala en
absoluto si me pongo por aquí la
península de baja california
esto es méxico
por acá está centroamérica por acá
arriba tengo la península de yucatán
y eeuu viene así por acá estaría la
península de florida y esto se va hacia
el norte que tendríamos california y
todo eso y se sigue hacia el norte
entonces qué significa esto pues si su
avión estuviera sobre la ciudad de
mexico que vamos a decir que está más o
menos por acá entonces acapulco está a
377 kilómetros por lo tanto el radio que
ustedes podrían ver es casi la distancia
de la ciudad méxico-acapulco es
muchísimo ok si hubieran en esta
dirección verían aproximadamente a 357
kilómetros en esta dirección
aproximadamente 357 kilómetros etcétera
etcétera o si estuvieran digamos en los
ángeles digamos que está por aquí
entonces casi casi podrían ver hasta la
ciudad de las vegas en cualquier
dirección la distancia de los ángeles a
las vegas' es 420 kilómetros una cosa
así
bueno una última observación es que eso
es la distancia
digamos en línea recta pero cuál sería
la distancia si quisieran caminar de
justo debajo del avión de este punto a
este otro punto los dejo que no ese
problema cuál sería la longitud de este
arco en la circunferencia pero bueno nos
vemos en la próxima